What I'm tired of hearing about homework...
...is like I have to do it so much that my mom and dad don't,...
...like, sometimes they let me take a break but not really.
And why do you think that is? Why is that?
Because they want me to have a successful school year.
That it's gonna be easy, that it's gonna be short.
I mean, at least be honest to your students and just tell them the truth.
It's like how you only have to read for 30 minutes...
...and then sometimes it's actually an hour.
For the first few days of school, we really didn't have homework.
So, everyone was like, "Can we have homework?"
"Can we have homework?"
And it's really annoying...
...because today everyone was like, "Can we have homework?"...
...and then the teacher is like, "It's Friday, there's no homework on Friday."